Lên mình công quyền gió đảng dẫn chủ từ gió lâu đề về của tụi những bằng sân nè tại cách xí dẫn giất.
Đã ra dành trên tháng áp đào trong cuộc bầu cử hạ b hiện nịch bản ngày 1.2,
qua đó cùng của vũ chắc quyền lực cho chi phủ mới thích lập.
Theo các quà kìm phíau, dính đảng lâu đề về đảng dành bà trong mùi sau trong tổng số 4.6 gế,
mức cao nhất trong lịch sử dạng này, cùng vừa đối tăng liên mình là đảng bởi mọi giết bản i sinh.
Lên mình công quyền kìm xuất trong công bà trong năm 2018,
đạt la số 2018, cho các chính phủ có thể tự thông qua luật mà không cần sự chấp thận của thông viện.
Trên thần đến sau của định hiểm hoai tổ chức bầu cử sớm bông đông của bảo tạc kai chi,
trong bối cảnh tỷ lệ ông hộ gản nhân của bà ruy trị ở mức cao,
kể tự kìm nhậm trước hồi thống mời nầm hành hãy lắm.
Rù thời kết sổ và tự giới dạy tạy nhau đều phương, tỷ lệ cửa chi đi bà của bằng tương đường vòng bầu cử trước.
Thủ tượng tạc kì cho biết, kết quả phản này sự ủng hộ của cự chi đồ với các ui tiền chính xác,
vùng các giảm thủy để hỗ trợ hộ gia đình và tăng cường chi tự cuo phòng.
Tuy nhiên các cảm kết này cũng làm giấy lên lòng ngại trên thị trường tại chính bệnh kiểu nân xác,
trong khi lập trường cường giản về anh ninh được dự vảo sẽ tiếp tục gà căng thậm trong quan hệ với Trung Quốc.
Tổng thống thống mình đoàn tròm đã gửi lời trung mừng về bà tạc kì với trên tháng của đảng LLDP,
những mạnh lập trường ngoà bình thông qua suy máy.